in this video I want to talk a little
bit about the initiation of translation
and I'm going to be talking about it
specifically involving prokaryotes and
then I'm going to talk about how you
carry out a little bit different towards
the end of the video so we want to start
off translation and translation is
taking mrna and turning it into proteins
now what we need is we need ribosomes to
come over to the mRNA and begin to
actually translate it so we know that
translation is supposed to start at a
yuji's but how do we know which Aug to
start at in prokaryotes they have this
little sequence called the
shine-dalgarno sequence oops
Garneau sequence and it's consists of a
few purine residues and shortly after
that the first Aug that follows the
shine-dalgarno sequence is where
translation initiates so it's at that
first Aug that follows the
shine-dalgarno sequence that's where we
want the ribosomes to go so what's going
to go over to the Aug first well there's
this 30 s ribosomal subunit that's going
to be the small ribosomal subunit and it
is going to go to that aug 30 s
initiation complex so that 30 s
initiation complex consists of four
different things those four different
things are of course the 30s subunit
itself the 30s ribosomal subunit so that
is the small ribosomal subunit so that
it's going to bring in and get ready to
incorporate the first amino acid so that
first amino acid or that first thing
that's going to incorporate is the
formulated methyl tRNA that's specific
for formulated Metheny so that's the F
met tRNA that is specific for F
that's going to come in also they're
also going to be joining the MRNA right
that's where they're going in the first
place they're going to this mRNA now a
lot of the fourth and final thing are
these things called initiation factors
these initiation factors come along with
the 30s ribosomal subunit so they all
come on over to the first Aug that
followed the shine-dalgarno sequence and
they're going to come over and form the
pre initiation complex so here we have
the formulated meth 19 so that's going
to come over so is the 30s probably some
one subunit with its initiation factors
and they're all going to come over to
the mRNA so now the first amino acid of
course that's going to be incorporated
is the formulated with Titan now once
this per unit or what's this initiation
complex forms the formation of this
complex recruits the 50s subunit which
is the large ribosomal subunit so then
this thing will now go over and join
this complex and that forms what is
called the 70s ribosomal ribosome now
you might be thinking 30s plus 50s that
doesn't equal 30 plus 50 doesn't equal
78 equals 80 and you're right but these
the S stands for sped burg units which
are units of the rate of sedimentation
and those units aren't actually not
additive so in this case just trust that
30 plus 50 equals 70 for the prokaryotic
ribosome so now once this happens there
is a gtp on one of these initiation
factors so if we have initiation factor
here initiation factor here there is a
gtp that is on this initiation factors
so this gtp is going to be hydrolyzed to
P and an inorganic phosphate and then
translation begins that's pretty much it
how is this different in eukaryotes
there are a few key differences Aug
start codon just like it is in
prokaryotes but eukaryotes they need a
specific tRNA called tRNA I which in the
I stands for initiator so this tRNA is
the initiator tRNA it's comparable to
the tRNA F net which is the initial the
initiator tRNA in prokaryotes the second
thing is that there is no shine-dalgarno
sequence the first Aug following the
five prime cap is where translation
begins so it's not the first Aug after a
particular sequence it's just the first
Aug that would come after the five prime
end of an mrna strand in a eukaryote is
where translation would begin there are
many initiation factors and they're
called a ifs and the e just stands for
eukaryotic the last thing is that the
small ribosomal subunit in eukaryotes is
40 s actually keep that in white it is
40 s and the large one is 60 s and you
might think that that will add up to a
hundred s that's not the case 40 s plus
60 s will equal an eighty s complete
ribosome so that's the difference in
eukaryotes otherwise it's pretty much
the same you form the small the or the
initiation complex with the small
ribosomal subunit the initial tRNA the
mRNA and some initiation factors and
then that'll recruit the larger side
reversible subunit and once that's there
you hydrolyze gtp and then translation
begins hope that video was helpful one
last thing I am a tutor if you live in
Southern California feel free to contact
me via
at move university at gmail.com and see
the description below for more details
thank you for watching